[Music]
are you being a good boy
are you being a good boy he's like no
i'm not
no no you're joking no
i can't do it i can't do it
i'm so excited to see you whenever i see
you two and of course
baby shy now i just feel so much love
and i think a lot of the other 90 day
fans feel the same way
so it's exciting to know that you're
going to be on 90 day foodie call
yes thank you what what can fans expect
from the show
well they can see that i can cook
because some people didn't think i could
cook
with the right guidance they're called
instructions
well what i love about the show as well
is that people get to chime in with
their questions
a lot of people are interested in your
sex life
we have sex i'm pregnant it's okay like
right and there's a baby sitting in your
lap
we're good does that flatter you at all
what are your thoughts
on that some things you have to keep to
yourself
of course for for a couple who's out
there and open with almost everything
it's nice to keep some things to
ourselves but like all the
like how's your day who cares how's your
sex life
people wanted to get to the juicy stuff
right away breezy
yeah well you are looked at as
one of the very few 90 day success
stories
so what would you say is the key to your
successful relationship
honey um
no it's not it's
unless she's pregnant you can use it
when she's pregnant i'm pregnant i have
a few months that i can get by with it
okay that's incredible i mean
we're very compatible together we
complete each other
yeah you could definitely i mean the
chemistry is just so authentic
you know but you know what if you would
have told us this seven years ago when
we met we probably would have laughed at
you
because it wasn't supposed to be this
like it was supposed to be a hookup and
that's
it right you stopped showing your twitch
oh my goodness what do you mean you're
not being a good boy look shy
is going to steal the interview i know
all of the comments are going to be
talking about how
my life he's really stealing my sunshine
yes and those little feet oh my goodness
he's so rude
what i love about you too is your
honesty with each other
you're real with each other it's super
authentic
i remember one of the episodes when you
were talking about starting a family
one of the main conversations you had to
have which was a real conversation
was about the possibility of the baby
having tourette's because
lauren has it what's your advice to
other couples on how to have those real
honest hard conversations because all of
this you you always
think about it ahead of time even if you
don't have the conversation it's in your
head
right so it's not like avoiding the
conversation you're gonna do anything so
just
put it out there and this way at least
everybody knows
like what you expect yeah
yeah lauren after you revealed
that you have tourette's and after you
became an ambassador
a lot of people felt seen by you coming
out and saying that somebody told me
that i
was their hero and i was kind of taken
back by that because i'm just
like i'm a regular girl i have a
platform
and i did this i opened up about it
selfishly to help me
because it really did help me and i
thought if i helped one person
then i did the right thing but i never
expected to be called a hero
or like this i don't know this support i
didn't know what to expect
because i didn't realize how many people
have truly affected
yeah because they never really talked
about it but now
i talk about it more and i'm very
comfortable in my skin
um and you know i do have my moments and
i've noticed them now with this
pregnancy they're definitely
a lot worse especially at night um
and there will be times where i text
them like i'm ticking so bad i don't
know why
i don't know what's going on and he's
like your body is changing like it's
your body releasing
the changes so he's been very
understanding and supportive but
i now understand
when it's affected most of the time you
know so it definitely helps me in my day
to day
you had a video a tlc video and you were
opening up
about your experience and a lot of
people were like yes this is what it
looks like it doesn't look like
you know it's not what people think at
all it's
a normal person and when you talk about
it you do it more because that's just
how it works
yeah but when it comes to like our kids
with it
it's not something that we talk about or
think about really because we
can't do anything and you
about it know there's nothing we can do
about it we're having
kids we're having a big family and
if any of them have it
[Music]
that's so beautiful how has your
marriage changed since becoming parents
i think it's
made us stronger no it definitely puts
you through a couple loops
but but we've gotten through it i think
it's actually taught us to communicate
more
for real like we talk about everything
now
and i think our problems are fighting
are gonna happen when they're older
because i'm like a nervous nelly now
it's just like no go head first and i'm
like oh no bugs
hand sanitizer you know so i think
that's
when our fighting is really going to
happen but for now i think it's really
made us stronger we see different sides
of each other
and you can still live life with babies
whoever is scared out there yeah you
can't oh my goodness
that's some really good advice and i
know lauren you were
hesitant at first about having a second
baby it was something that you were like
i don't know we're quite ready for it
you're president about everything we're
having about the first one also
it's so funny because like i'm enjoying
this pregnancy and i'm excited
but this guy over here already wants to
ask the doctor if i can do three under
three
and i'm like whoa let's see what did i
want to do
it i just want to know it's awesome
but i don't know if this has the
information oh my goodness
already you're thinking about that
already alex
how big of a family do you want my
family do you want
at least three yeah that's so sweet
i get it lauren you know you have to
carry the baby but it's nice to know
that you're married to a man that wants
to continue to make more of
you all you know that's so cute
that is a good way to put it because
right now
yeah that's true he's mr personality
he's very me so i'll take
it but let me tell you i am i am hot and
heavy right now in florida
and i still have a few more months to go
but i told him if we do this again
let's do it like in the summer so i go
through a winter pregnancy again
how do you think he's going to react to
a new baby in the house that's the most
exciting thing for me that's what i want
to see
i want to see shy how he's going to like
be a big brother
how he's going to be with the new baby
so
it's funny because i'm seeing it
differently so he obviously
babies are very intuitive like i think
he can feel what's happening
and he's very attached to me and i work
from home so
i'm at my computer all day and he's like
grabbing me
and like he just wants my attention so
i'm actually kind of nervous
he'll get used to it a few you know a
few days at the beginning
but he does put his head on my belly
like when we're laying in bed he lays
his head on my belly shia are you going
to be a big brother
yeah no yes you are no
so whatever he's going to say no
[Music]
everything